[Musique]
coincé entre le mexique et le guatemala
le belize est une ancienne colonie
britannique
indépendant depuis à peine 30 ans il
attire touristes et investisseurs
américains
seuls 36 français profitent de cet
eldorado
pendant plusieurs semaines nous avons
suivi le destin de cinq d'entre eux
manon tient l'unique crêperie du belize
en bordure de plage
les affaires marchent bien elle a décidé
de se lancer dans l'immobilier et de
vendre des terrains sur des îles
désertes
laurent et chef de cuisine dans un grand
hôtel
sa table est réputé dans tout le pays
cette semaine il doit préparer le repas
d'un grand mariage
[Applaudissements]
depuis un an et demi catherine et arnaud
parcourt le monde à la recherche d'un
coin de paradis ils ont pris un aller
simple pour le belize quand nos valises
dans la toute ma vie
c'est tout ce qui nous reste de la ville
avant
si les fonds marins sont à la hauteur de
leurs attentes
ils ouvriront un club de plongée
enfin nadège a choisi de vivre loin de
tout avec tom son mari elle a construit
un lodge au coeur de la forêt tropicale
de tout ça nous garde jeune
je pense j'espère
dans quelques semaines la visite d'une
agence de voyage française pourrait
l'aider à réussir son pari ah oui ça
l'est particulièrement grande
vivre de son rêve au milieu de la jungle
kiko coeur est l'une des îles les plus
paisibles du pays
dans la rue principale
un petit coin de france
bonjour comment ça va aujourd'hui
après avoir voyagé pendant une dizaine
d'années manon une jeune cannois s'est
installé ici il y a deux ans
je me suis dit il faut que je fasse
quelque chose de différent qui a pas sur
l'île et c'est vrai que ma nourriture ne
manquait puis apparemment j'ai vu juste
étant donné que ça marche très bien
elle a même embauché trois salariés
coupe tous les fruits
et après tu en fais les tranches
la bacon fromage le jaune d'oeuf et au
milieu il va couler dans la crève
l'appétit
ses clients découvrent avec surprise la
spécialité de manon
c'est tout fin et mettre à l'intérieur
d'une crêpe un oeuf au plat j'aurais
jamais pensé à ça c'est délicieux on n'a
rien de comparable aux états unis être
au belize et manger ça c'est juste
incroyable
en cuisine les nouveaux venus suivre une
formation crêpes bretonnes
tu vois tu appuies trop avec la spatule
vas-y moins fort plus vite
c'est la première fois que je fais ça
c'est un peu dur mais bon j'ai envie
d'apprendre
tu peut la retourner mais ces attentions
saadé côté un peu difficile étant donné
que je suis jeune j'ai eu des employés
avec un peu plus d'expérience et c'est
vrai que les accepte mal 20 qu'une
gamine de 25 cents leur dise quoi faire
après c'est pour ça que l'ag que des
jeunes comme ça je peux les former à ma
façon de travailler
vous voulez une photo ensemble
elle est prêt
et voilà
l'établissement de manon affiche complet
presque tous les jours
[Musique]
le matin à la fin de chaque service
elles seront sur le continent pour y
faire ses courses
bonjour un billet pour belize city s'il
vous plaît
quarante cinq minutes de bateau
bus
c'est magnifique alors basta non voulues
ya pire pour
chercher pour aller faire les courses
par an et puis y'a pas de circulation
donc c'est le bus sans les inconvénients
au marché de belize city manon a ses
habitudes
comment tu vas bien
avec les fruits elle fait des confitures
pour ses crêpes tuer des mangues n'ont
pas aujourd'hui
je vais prendre des papayes alors
avec moi quand j'étais jeune ma grand
mère tirait sur la feuille pour savoir
si le fruit était mûr au belize vous
faites pareil vous avez une autre
technique ont fait pareil mais la
plupart des gens vont regarder si
d'ananas et jaune 6 et jaune comme celui
là c'est qu'il est mûr
ça va pas
bon
ok
de retour sur l'île manon assure un
nouveau service
la crêpes au sirop d'érable et c'est là
la banane flambée super merci ben ali
[Rires]
c'est lors des comptes
46 ça fait 444 444 $ béliziens
l'équivalent de 250 euros pour être
rentable avec tous les frais faut que je
fasse à peu près 30 euros par jour donc
sachant que j'ai le service du matin et
du soir on va dire que à partir de 15
euros le matin
ça va
la crêperie fonctionne bien alors manon
se lance dans un tout autre domaine
beaucoup plus risqué
des risques elle n'est pas la seule à en
prendre
à l'intérieur du pays dans la jungle qui
entoure le village de san ignacio
l'accès est souvent difficile
c'est pourtant là que nadège a décidé de
s'installer
bonjour
je suis nadège
sans ça on chante et on va vous prendre
vos bagages vous venez de ça dans ma
voiture et puis on va vous emmener venir
aujourd'hui nadège accueille un couple
de français en voyage de noces
direction son lodge au coeur de la
jungle
cette petite route et les good run et
jusqu'à présent mais bientôt il y aura
plus et c'est un petit peu
elle est pleine de nids de poule et puis
on a cédé plus d'ennemis poule cdéné de
deux vaches oui c'est facile voilà
c'est la première fois que je vais dans
la jungle un bon super beau c'est très
très jolie oui
et alors pourquoi vous avez choisi
belize hausse et a dit le belly c'est
bien c'est pas connu des français
soutient prises quatre accusés on a su
que vous étiez française
a failli et en hiver vous y êtes
la plupart des clients de nadège sont
américains ou asiatiques
ce matin pour les français elle s'occupe
elle-même de la présentation des lieux
donc alors ceci sera votre chambre à
l'eau
est rentré
votre chambre
[Musique]
la chambre coûte 300 euros la nuit
si vous allez vous vous baladez un peu
le dans la soirée en fait on a des
lumières mais pas partout donc je vous
conseillerais de de l'apprendre je vous
montrez votre petit bal qu ici
rentrée oui avec une jolie vue sur la
rivière
prison
nadège retrouve son mari pour une
réunion avec le personnel
allez monte
c'est une belle journée mon coeur oui
chaque jour qui passe est une belle
journée ils gèrent ensemble cette
propriété de 72 hectares en route pour
la réunion
bonjour tout le monde
comment s'est passé le trajet pour venir
jusqu'ici il vient au frais un peu frais
oui
des nouveaux clients arrivent
aujourd'hui chambre 7
probablement vers 16h 16h30 donc faites
bien attention à ce que tout soit
parfait autour de la chambre
merci beaucoup
on a déjà appris à s'imposer au milieu
de tous ces hommes
ce travail c'est le travail d'une vraie
chef d'entreprise quand on est à 42 43
employés il faut vraiment être organisé
merci tout le monde pour la réunion
allez maintenant au boulot catwalk
merci
avant de venir au belize nadège a passé
22 ans au canada elle travaillait dans
la finance
en 2007 elle a revendu son entreprise et
sa maison pour s'installer ici au bord
de la rivière marcal mais au coeur de la
jungle
la gestion de l'hôtel est souvent
compliqué
qu'est ce qui ne va pas
tomtom pour nadège
on a un problème avec internet ça
fonctionne
d'accord j'arrive
la représentante d'une agence de voyages
vient dans quelques jours
la panne doit être réparée avant son
arrivée
à 200 km de là sur la côte la presqu'île
de placentia
c'est ici que travail laurent
salut beau gosse comment ça va me gaëlle
bien et vous super merci
ils commencent toutes ses journées par
le même rituel
les vacanciers dorment encore et laurent
peut profiter sol de la piscine
génial finalement après l'effort le
réconfort
cuisinier il s'est installé au belize
avec sa femme et sa fille il y a deux
ans sans mal des phrases en ce moment la
chance le cadre est idyllique
mais le boulot n'est pas de tout repos
tu m'appelles quand les premiers clients
arrivent ok je vous appellerai
chez le petit moment où est-ce qu'on se
retrouve en famille un peu plus
facilement par rapport au service du
soir et est en général le midi elle
n'est pas là puisqu'elle part à l'école
c'est vraiment le petit moment où où on
prend néanmoins l'ensemble quoi ça c'est
bon ça
bonté sont ces faits évidemment demandé
madame éveiller les déposer au retour
tout est prêt pour le tour 1 le poisson
j'ai fait trois gros poissons comme ça
des maï maï qu'on a reçu hier justement
avec le co planète et en même temps vous
avez un grand saladier des fruits de
tout merci merci valable mais
bon j'y vais mois donc on se voit
peut-être avant tu pars tu mens un bond
à l'elysée les filles
parmi ses spécialités
le homard
[Applaudissements]
c'est un produit de luxe qu'on arrive
facilement à trouver dans la mer ici il
suffit de sortir à quelques kilomètres
en pleine mer et il empêche énormément
ici c'est bon il y en a trop d'hermach
on mange mais que ça
laurent adapte sa carte au pays dans
lequel il vit j'ai travaillé douze ans
en afrique j'ai travaillé à dubaï je
viens tu as et quatre aux états unis et
en même temps on a vécu deux ans en
guyane et deux ans en allemagne avec ma
femme donc effectivement c'est aussi on
appelle ça aventure et c'est sur ces
savants durée j'ai passé quand même les
trois quarts de ma vie à l'étranger
ici ils cuisinent pour de riches
touristes
et on va leur faire une petite sauce
termites or à base de beurre des
américains adorent manger des
délais homard avec du beurre à l'ail
tout simplement maintenant les
américains sont pas très compliqué 1 1
voilà bravo ma belle bouge plus alors
c'est le petit homard des caraïbes avec
une fille croquettes de risotto les
américains adorent ce qui crispe ifo du
croquant il faut du craquant dans mon
assiette donc là on met lass a tout
simplement avec des petits cerfs un
petit beurre aillé une petite risotto
croquettes un petit peu de parmesan on
sa passe est très simple ramener
sa femme nadège travaille avec lui c'est
la boulangère de l'hôtel
en cuisine le reste de l'équipe ne parle
qu'espagnol
je n'avais jamais travaillé avec un
français on a parfois du mal à
communiquer mais quand le chef parle de
cuisine ça va on finit par se comprendre
entre deux services
lors on retrouve son ami roberto
sayad et bret
roberto et italiens
c'est parti pour quatre mois comme ça à
5 ans et 6 mois non-stop cette chaleur
donc quelques jours roberto se marie
laurent et son témoin
une occasion très importants comme un
mariage bien sûr tout va chercher
personnes qu'elles sont extrêmement
importante dans ta vie et lauranne c'est
un bon ami
et ça des fois et un bon psychologue
depuis
été une adhésion
lors on sera à la fois témoin et
cuisiniers pour le mariage de son amie
catherine et arnaud aussi un défi de
vente e à bientôt 50 ans ce couple de
français a décidé de changer de vie cela
fait 18 mois qu'il parcourt le monde ils
viennent tout juste d'arriver au belize
donc là on est sur la rue principale
voilà c'est les champs elysées d'ici
au tarif là tu es touristes tu te dis
quoi sa page très sympa c'est super
mignon cette voiture c'est super mignon
c'est des maisons en bois c'est beaucoup
de couleurs c'est du jaune du bleu du
vert 2
voilà c'est
sans doute ce que les billysiens ont
dans la tête plein de couleurs le lagon
la barrière de corail au loin
donc la première première l'impression
où on entend les elle est vraiment
positive
bien moi je voudrais bien loué
à latine et fais toi plaisir
est super chaude
au bord elle fait
elle fait plus de 30
bon moi j'ai hâte de voir qu'il ya des
dessous
à paris catherine travaillait dans les
ressources humaines arnaud lui dirigé
une entreprise de 80 salariés le couple
a tout plaqué pour créer un club de
plongée on avait tous
professionnels on était dans le confort
mais à un moment donné on avait envie
d'avoir un autre rythme c'est vrai qu'à
paris bon il ya un certain stress il ya
je pense qu'une fois qu'on s'est
réalisée on a envie d'autre chose on se
rapproche de ce que l'on a au plus
profond de soi et
il a fallu cette année avant pour
peut-être avoir compris et et après ceux
réalisés dans autre chose alors tout ça
c'est un prix ça un prix parce que
quitter un pays s'est quittés d'abord
nos enfants c'est quitter la famille
c'est qu'ils étaient des amis donc un
moment donné d'une vie on a envie d'être
un peu égoïste et de penser à soi
voilà
bon alors tu dois vivre ici ou
un si je me vois vivre ici n'as tu vois
je ne sais pas pour l'instant mais je me
vois bien la première impression est
bonne ah bon oui tout de suite déjà vu
thi
première étape pour le couple trouver un
logement
vous avez une vue sur le lagon
juste en face
voici le salon
la cuisine
il y à un sèche-linge un lave linge
là c'est la chambre avec climatisation
et ventilateur
[Musique]
briguer une grande terrasse qui est
agréable bon après la déco et ça c'est
une question de goût mais on a des
causes c'est pas ça on va pas refaire
mon nom non mais bon il ya tout
nécessaire pour s'installer près les
grands pour deux mais comment
tu en penses quoi toi
mais mille euros par mois pour 60 m² une
mauvaise surprise pour catherine et
arnaud avant d'arriver au belize ils ont
vécu en asie où la vie était beaucoup
moins cher qu'ici
on avait une villa avec piscine sur un
golf en thaïlande donc donc forcément il
ya des écarts maintenant
le marché c'est ça on va voir ce à quoi
on peut prétendre en visitant d'autres
choses bien
aller
le couple attend avec impatience la
première plongée pour vérifier la
qualité des fonds marins et décider s'il
reste au belize
aujourd'hui la crêperie de manon est
fermé
et arrive à trouver quand même des
choses une amie française est venue lui
rendre visite
[Musique]
ça chouette qui fasse
depuis quelques jours
mais là on fait on est en période haute
c'est ça
sacré hiver
elle s'est très vite habituée à la vie
locale
bien souvent à quito coeur qui dit
gosso première manque donc ce qui veut
dire allez-y doucement
et ensuite
ça dit donc nos choses nous chargeons
nos problèmes nos monnaies big problem
ça veut dire en gros si vous n'avez pas
de chaussures si vous n'avez pas de tee
shirt je n'ai pas de problème par contre
si vous n'êtes pas d'argent j'avais un
gros problème
ces pauvres petites averses pourraient
pas mal
manon a quitté la france à l'âge de 16
ans elle a déjà travaillé au japon en
thaïlande en australie en nouvelle
zélande son installation au belize est
un choix mûrement réfléchi
j'avais envie de vraiment exotisme
cocotiers manger des cocos quand je me
lève le matin et d'ananas voilà
on parle anglais ici il ya la deuxième
barrière de corail mondiale après celle
de l'australie dont c'est vraiment un
argument de vente un argument commercial
qui est vraiment important dans
n'importe quel business que je vais
pouvoir ouvrir et puis j'avais vraiment
envie d'une nouvelle vie son parcours
impressionne sa copine
c'est quelqu'un de très courageux c'est
quelqu'un qui a pas peur de demain qui a
pas peur de deûle aventure qui n'a pas
peur de l'inconnu manon n'ya rien
qu'elle ne peut pas faire en fait c'est
vrai c'est vrai tout ce qu'elle
entreprend elle réussit elle peut être
fière d'elle
un peu mal à la
super copine je suis consciente que pour
l'âge que j'ai fait quand même beaucoup
de choses mais pour moi c'est les autres
cas font passer donc je trouve que je
trouve que je pourrai encore par plus
d'accord
finalement direction la barrière de
corail à quelques minutes seulement de
la plage
[Musique]
les requins ares une tuerie
d'ailleurs déclaré je vais dans l'eau
c'est
[Applaudissements]
pour marie la copine de manon c'est une
première
ici
la faune est particulièrement riche
elle est pas belle la vie
je suis content non non c'est comme si
tu donnes et d'emploi j'adore parce
qu'on voit tout c'est magique quoi bon
pour le coup
des requins nourrices
ils ne sont pas dangereux
ça
ouais
ça c'est l'écart est plus bien comment
ça fait du bien de couper et des fois je
trouve qu'à une journée c'est trop court
et les périodes où je vais prendre un
peu plus de jour de perdre un bon mois
mais pas sur ans j'habite sur une île
pour ce genre d'excursion également
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le repos a été de courte durée
ce matin manon un avion à prendre
elle ne compte pas se limiter à la
restauration
votre carte d'embarquement j'espère que
vous reviendrez oui j'habite ici il
revient ce soir aujourd'hui je vais
créer une nouvelle société à la capitale
et dans tout ce qui est gestion
patrimoine donc
on y va
le belize compte de nombreuses îles
vierges
une aubaine pour manon
elle souhaite dénicher des terrains
porte des investisseurs
bonjour j'aimerais créer mon entreprise
pourriez vous me donner les formulaires
à remplir
vous remplissez là et là
ça va prendre combien de sang deux à
trois heures à peu près super parfait
le belize facilite les démarches pour
les créateurs d'entreprise
qu'il me faut pour ouvrir ma société
ensuite je devrais payer 10 euros et ce
sera
c'est aussi une des raisons pour
laquelle il choisit le belize et la
facilité administratif le fait est qu'il
est bon de papier et en anglais ça
change quand même déjà beaucoup de
choses pas besoin de traducteur pas
besoin de
de paperasse énorme et c'est tout c'est
vraiment agréable
de pouvoir faire simplement les choses
voilà
la nouvelle activité est lancé
quelques jours plus tard manon a rendez
vous avec un promoteur américain il met
en vente des terrains exceptionnel
le terrain il est bien constructibles on
peut y mettre un hôtel ou des bungalows
tout est possible à partir du moment où
ça respecte l'environnement
c'est encore abordables d'acheter la
plage c'est matin se faire parce que tu
déjà les prix des terrains ont quadruplé
en deux ans
je vais prendre quelques photos pour mes
clients
il arrive
la mangrove occupe une grande partie de
l'île la moitié restera une réserve
naturelle
l'autre est constructible
ces deux terrains sont encore
disponibles pour environ 120 milles
euros
6 arrêtant de 200000 euros ils sont
susceptibles d'être intéressés par ces
deux terrains qui sont en front de mer
puis en en achetant deux j'espère avoir
un bon prix
[Musique]
ouais j'ai déjà les plans dans la tête
ça va vraiment plaire à mon client et je
suis quasiment sûr que le projet va être
validé la c7 hop voilà
manon espère convaincre son acheteur et
faire sa première vente d'îles désertes
dans la jungle tout ne va pas aussi bien
pour nadège
internet ne fonctionne toujours pas et
l' agence de voyage arrive bientôt pour
évaluer son hôtel
qu'est ce qui se passe alors mon amour
je crois que j'ai trouvé le problème ma
chérie
tom son mari de 72 ans va essayer de
réparer la panne
tu vois cette grosse branche elle touche
le pylône et c'est peut-être ça qui
bloque le système en faisant des
interférences alors ce que je vais faire
c'est que je vais monter là haut pour
couper la branche
ok mais fais attention tu viens m'aider
à mettre noir n'est
bien sûr
mais toi derrière -
il ya toujours une raison pour laquelle
je fais les choses elle est là
[Rires]
mubi tom fait attention là haut
t'inquiète pas chérie
ne restent pas juste en dessous ok je me
bouge
[Rires]
ce qu on est arrivé ici je me suis
renseigné auprès du fournisseur d'accès
à internet qui a équipé le village d'à
côté il m'a répondu que c'était
impossible de nous relier au réseau
alors j'ai dû faire moi-même
l'installation de tous et je crois que
ça nous garde jeune
je pense j'espère
neige
est ce qu'internet est revenu
c'est super merci
bonne nouvelle tout fonctionne
j'ai gagné un bisou
[Applaudissements]
le problème résolu
nadège peut aller nourrir ses petits
protégés
je mets des fruits pour les oiseaux on a
beaucoup d'oiseaux qui viennent les
manger et puis alors en fait nos invités
peuvent regarder les oiseaux
il appelle ses ses copains pour leur
dire que leur paille est prêt
les tous qu'on vienne picorer
les clients de l'hôtel n'en perdent pas
une miette
ok ça c'est le jet les gestes des
voleurs ils prennent et s'envole ils
partent
ce serait peut-être une des raisons pour
laquelle je suis ici de voir la nature
de près comme ça ça m'émeut quand même c
sauf que c'est magnifique et c'est
quelque chose que les gens de la ville
non non pas l'occasion de voir
en fin de journée nadège fait le tour de
son hôtel
lloyd est ce que vous avez tendu la
pelouse au secours de la réception du
spa du restaurant tout ça s'est fait
tout est fait on a aussi fait l'entrée
de l'hôtel pour la visite de demain
ok génial merci beaucoup à plus tard il
aida on a cette visite qui est très
importante demain c'est une dame qui
fait partie d'un groupe d'une agence de
voyage est là ses clients sont le ce
sont des clients européens et alors nous
on veut vraiment donner une très bonne
impression parce que cette agence
pourrait peut-être nous ouvrir les
portes sur le marché européen et je
voulais être sûr que tout soit parfait
si nadège et si stressée c'est parce que
l' agence de voyage est déjà venu
l'année dernière et n'avait pas
sélectionné son hôtel
veronica est ce que vous pourriez elle
avait la rousse de la chaise longue
avant demain s'il vous plaît
faites sport c'est bon j'espère que
notre fontaine aura du succès il faudra
bien faire attention de qu'elle soit
allumée demain
l'avenir de nadège au belize est en jeu
son hôtel n'est pas rentable un bon
référencement par l' agence de voyages
permettrait d'attirer une nouvelle
clientèle
pour laurent aussi le stress monte
le mariage de son ami roberto approche
avec sa femme ils attaquent la
préparation du gâteau
et m'ont demandé à un gâteau tout blanc
avec des étoiles de mer qui rappelle la
mère parce qu'ils se marient sur la
plage
pourquoi que le race il ya pas de gâteau
de rechange l'habitude ça tombe très
très bien et là ça fonce et c'est très
difficile à travailler
il fait trop chaud en cuisine on est
comme en chirurgie en fait il faut
éponger c'est parce que là c'est un
travail où il fait 31 degrés là
maintenant et c'est bien que le fondant
soit pas trop salée quoi c'est plutôt
une affaire de sucre
une fois le gâteau risque de souffrir
laurent et nadège décide de le
transporter dans leur chambre climatisée
en attendant le mariage le couple
s'accorde un peu de répit avec les
premiers invités déjà arrivés sur place
bonjour
attention ne tombait pas on monte à bord
on va mettre une crevette comme ap un
bon une crevette ce qui va arriver dans
nos minutes
pêche du gros la lecture rota sont ainsi
81 kg de poissons
là là il a mangé la crevette on risque
pas de mon goût de poisson ce soit n'est
pas très doué
au mérou
hasina mais là c'est énorme la prise que
je viens de faire
ma gauche et il est vivant
et comment il a fait pour se mettre dans
cette dernière la soie son
stop to move levé
dans le look at me now that
hyper spécialisés qui a peur d'un
méchant petit poisson de 50 g 15 $ de
crevettes pour pêcher finalement un
poisson un dollar
[Rires]
je vais t'apprendre à pêcher tu vas
apprendre à cuisiner
de retour à l'hôtel une mauvaise
surprise attend laurent et nadège
on a laissé la porte ouverte de la
maison et le fondant il a pris une
claque
catastrophe
il ya dessus j'ai plus rien qu'à lice
dans deux mois un vol
tu vas leur courrier aux boules de
maintenant on va faire comment ces démos
de prendre ça comme ça ah bah tant pis
c'est un cas d'urgence a
commencé ça demain ben tu peux pas vous
dire tu m'en vais regarder cela puis a
commencé cette partie d'ac avec la
vapeur
d'eau moins de 24 heures il faudra
servir le gâteau aux invités
avant d'ouvrir leurs clubs de plongée
catherine et arnaud font une étude de
marché
bonjour
il ya combien de clubs de plongée sur
l'île il y en a six mon mari et moi on a
l'un des plus petits
et vous savez s'il y en a un à vendre
pour le moment non
on peut plonger tout le long de la
barrière de corail et on a aussi trois
atolls on peut y voir une vie marine
très diversifiée des requins des raids
des tortues mais ça s'annonce plutôt
bien six centres de plongée pour
pour une île comme qui colle coeur qu'il
ya autour d'elle un potentiel aussi
impressionnant que celui là je trouve
pas ça énorme et le gros avantage
c'est qu'on n'a pas vu un seul centre de
plongée francophones y en a pas
maintenant ce qu'il reste à valider
c'est ce qu'on veut en dessous donc il
faut plutôt s'assurer que ce qu'on voit
au fond c'est un anglophone
l'île voisine de san pedro et la mecque
des plongeurs au belize catherine et
arnaud prospects les différents sites
alentours
le couple veut aussi vérifier les
conditions de sécurité
aujourd'hui ils visitent le seul caisson
de décompression du belize si la
remontée du plongeur est trop rapide
le caisson peut lui sauver la vie on a
la capacité de soigner trois patients en
même temps
on y entre
trois personnes à nant
après finale à mais un mec à mettre 90
110 kg bah oui mais les gens ils
s'empilent pas ils sont assis les uns à
côté des autres en a ils peuvent pas
être ni racinien non non mais reste là
reste de la can you close on peut fermer
la porte
ils ont tout nécessaire j'en pense que
ya pas de question à se poser
c'est pau même si on a la responsabilité
en tant que plongeur et guides d'ondés
d'emmener nos clients sous l'eau offert
un tour et les ramener en vie en bonne
santé il est important de savoir que le
derrière
il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir
traiter un éventuel problème est qu'ils
puisaient 24/24
ses yeux
causent un usineur
qui avant de poursuivre leurs recherches
arnaud et catherine prennent quelques
conseils auprès de manon même si on a
décidé de s'installer dans cette région
là
si on place le compas sur 10 qu'alger la
pointe du combat on peut tracer un
cercle à l'aide d'une quinzaine de
kilomètres on sait que c'est globalement
dans cet environnement là que les choses
doivent se passer ce soit qui colle
coeur sans mauvais drainage génial en
face ou quoi que ce soit voilà c'est ça
au niveau économique étant de laisser
seul pays d'amérique centrale s'est pas
enlevé par rapport à tous les canadiens
et tous les américains qui parlent
qu'anglais évidence ces gens là force
plutôt que d'en écouter les vidéos les
français du belize centre est volontiers
pour faciliter les nouvelles
installations
envie de pouvoir
partager et maintenant elle est plutôt
de bon conseil il fait qu'elle habite
ici depuis yeux des boutons du fait
qu'elle ait un bon pif d'ubs et du fait
qu'elle ait entrepris du fait qu'elle
est la tête sur les épaules malgré son
jeune âge
c'est rassurant
ses cartons
bonjour mike commenta les bleus
bienvenue à petit cocker
aujourd'hui manon accueille son premier
client un riche hôteliers du belize
c'est lui qui recherche un terrain pour
construire des loges
les parcelles commence tu ici la plage
va jusqu'au bout là bas et ça traverse
toute l'île
les bungalows pourraient être construits
de ce côté on va aller voir
ma vie
bienvenue chez vous
il faut des autorisations spéciales pour
aménager la mangrove
oui le vendeur les a
alors ces parcelles elles sont à combien
du coup ça c'est mon travail de négocier
il ya des lots à vendre à partir de
90000 euros mais ça devrait pouvoir se
négocier aux alentours de 60 peut-être
même un peu moins ça dépend du nombre de
lots que vous voulez acheter
regardez un peu le sable
la qualité est excellente si vous
aménagez que vous enlevez les
broussailles garder ce sable c'est une
qualité très fines comme de la farine
vous pourriez aménager des petites
plages privées entouré par la mangrove
ce serait magnifique et vous pourriez
faire des petites criques
un jour un vieux monsieur m'a appris que
lorsqu'il y a des cocotiers quelque part
c'est que le terrain est en bonne santé
donc ça me rassure le terrain me semble
pas mal
des locaux me fasse confiance pour moi
c'est vraiment une belle carte j'en suis
fier parce que ça veut dire qu'ils
pensent que je peux même mieux négocié
que donc je suis vraiment très très
contente
à 25 ans il m'aurait été impossible
d'investir comme ça autant en france au
belize main tout est possible c'est
juste parfait leurs violons
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nadège va être notés par une
agence de voyages malgré son stress elle
ne change rien à ses habitudes
les fromages français et comme c'est
impossible de trouver ça belize city la
meilleure solution pour moi c'était de
les faire moi même
la jeune femme qui fait l'inspection
représente l'une des plus grandes
agences françaises elle fait une tournée
pour référencer plusieurs hôtels au
belize
type d'hôtels de luxe forcément évident
à proposer à la clientèle européenne il
faut savoir que les billets d'avion pour
venir dans une région comme le bélize
c'est un sacré budget depuis la france
ça tourne facilement autour de 950 euros
avec trente heures de vol pour venir
donc les gens investissent déjà une
bonne partie de leur budget là dedans ce
qui fait qu'après c'est un peu compliqué
dur c'est plus la flexibilité sur les
hébergements et les activités
ça c'est la chambre principale à et qui
a sont axées sur la terre sur la
terrasse bah oui cela elle est
particulièrement grande oui oui c'est
une pile alors la vue sur la rivière
c'est un sacré blues
donc on arrive à notre sport
ah oui c'est vrai ce que vous avez fait
quel type de massage vous proposez à
votre clientèle ici le massage dit échu
ont fait le massage suédois
les huiles qu'on utilise pour les
massages on les fait ici nous mêmes
vous avez beaucoup de gens qui font du
yoga non
je voudrais que vous essayez ce fromage
de chèvre vous fabriquez oui et on à
ajouter de l'ail et des herbes le goût
de la provence il est bon
et bien farine alors voilà la visite se
termine qu'est ce que vous en pensez que
les gens qui viennent en couple plutôt
que de les envoyer directement sur les
îles on pourrait intégrer plus
facilement ça comme étant une étape pour
qu'ils aillent voir un petit peu les
activités à faire autour de nature de
jungle d'excursion dont l'écouté pour
moi
c'est un très bel établissement c'est
beaucoup c'est une récompense formidable
pour moi de savoir que si ça plaît aux
gens et bien c'est ça a été du travail
bien fait et puis si en plus on peut
avoir plus de clients de clients
européens de clients français
c'est encore c'est encore mieux ça veut
dire qu'on a réussi
comme catherine et arnaud les plongeurs
du monde entier viennent au belize pour
ce site
le blue hole
un trou géant de 120 mètres de
profondeur
yes
quand j'étais gamin je voulais pas de
charme d'antan pis moi je voulais être
je voulais être sur la calypso avec le
commandant cousteau voilà ce que je
voulais faire moi et il se trouve que
c'est un endroit qui l'a découvert au
début des années 70 donc c'est un petit
peu comme marcher sur ses pas là c'est
la plongée c'est la journée
vous allez voir le beau rôle à la forme
d'un verre à cocktail
tapissé de coraux et la paroisse
s'incline à 45 degrés à vous de jouer
man est fait
c'est ça c'est fait
et là on n'est pas déçu on nous dit
qu'il ya des réserves ces potagers
bah ça s'avère très parce qu'on voit
vraiment mon abandon pouvoir d'aquarium
du dedans ah ben c'est ce à quoi
entre autres un beau pays de beaux
paysages
un coup de coeur
riddell plongez donc
bah tout de suite je vois pas ce qu'on
retient de
restez
voilà et d'habiter là voilà
comme vous mais d'avoir esprits
à l'élastique
à plasencia
pour laurent le cuistot le grand jour
est arrivé et ce matin je suis cuisinier
je m'organise pour le mariage cet après
midi je fais garçons d'honneur à ce
mariage puisque c'est un ami donc c'est
un petit challenge aujourd'hui c'est un
peu spécial on n'a pas fait pire mais ça
va aller lucho lucho caliente lac alors
non est ce que j'ai fait
dans la chambre climatisée
la femme de laurent tente de sauver le
gâteau de mariage
ça fait des heures que je travaille pour
qu'ils puissent être joli cd album je
les ai fait sécher pour pouvoir les
mettre sur le gâteau aujourd'hui
bon ben voilà il est terminée parfait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
rome décidé aujourd'hui roberto et
wilmar ici présents vont s'unir pour
partager leur vie ensemble dans les
liens sacrés du mariage
je t'aimerai pour toujours tué l'amour
de ma vie
[Applaudissements]
comment j'aurais pu imaginer qu'un jour
j'allais marié un ami mobilise en tant
que témoin non c'est quand même quelque
chose que je crois qu'il est assez
exceptionnel ça fait toujours chaud au
coeur évidemment comme dans les petites
choses comme ça
halak est
[Applaudissements]
sombre nous on est heureux si vous
n'êtes pas quelqu'un qui est qui aimait
partager ça sert à rien de faire
cuisiner un peu pour rien à manger
changerez cette vie quoi même si c'est
un petit peu dur de temps en temps on a
quand même des petites pauses détendre
relâche donc voilà à quoi
c'est la vie
[Applaudissements]
cela fait maintenant trois ans que
laurent et sa femme vivent à plasencia
et ils entendent poursuivre encore
longtemps leur aventure dans les
caraïbes manon aussi devrait y rester
quelques temps elle a réalisé sa
première vente de terrains sur une île
déserte depuis elle a mis sa crêperie en
gérance et se consacre à sa nouvelle
activité dans l'immobilier
nadège a enfin reçu la bonne nouvelle
qu'elle attendait son hôtel fait
désormais partie du catalogue d'un grand
voyagiste français
enfin catherine et arnaud ont décidé de
s'installer ici
ils ont entamé les démarches pour
obtenir un titre de séjour
ils seront désormais 38 français au
belize